what the next thing that seems to be the
hot trend now is people want to figure
out a way to get offline to become to
become unglue to get some of their
anonymity back and you know they're
saying right now that all our key
strokes are being monitored all that
stuff I don't want to go into every
level of the paranoia stuff but do you
guys does this idea appeal to you and
we've talked about it on this show a
couple of times before but the idea that
people are going to be paying to erase
their stuff already there are bars that
are saying you know you're not going to
wear Google glasses here that holding is
this all the future would you would you
want to reset and disappear from the
internet if you could good piece of
advice if you want to remove yourself
off of google move to Madagascar like
move somewhere there just isn't a lot
going on the internet crazy animals
change your name to jennifer smith yeah
I mean I actually understand this
especially because first of all you can
make mistakes when you're younger there
can be things about you on the Internet
aren't necessarily true things you
participate in whether it's like a
television show or pictures of you out
at night those things stay and then you
evolve as a person and then you go crap
there's this whole me on the internet so
unless you've been super sappy about
branding yourself you can either look
all over the place on the internet or
there could be things you simply just
don't want on there I was born with a
different last name so I have a birth
certificate in a passport that is a
different last name and now it's legally
been changed to Jen Hoffman like that's
my legal name is Hoffman but was that
because of stage name or no I was on my
mother married someone who adopted me
when I was 11 months old so then changed
to that last name so my dad's last name
that I carry now instead of rather than
my mother's maiden name which is was all
my birth certificate I think all the
time about changing it back to that just
so when people Google me nothing comes
up so you can start with a fresh slate
because there's assumptions people make
about you and if you work in any sort of
industry and people are booking you that
really great you were great for this oh
but we googled you and found out that
you once worked in entertainment so
that's inappropriate for news or if you
were news it was inappropriate for this
or you were blonde in these pictures
that confuses us because we like you
better brunette I mean it's so
ridiculous how that stuff really does
catch up with you so yeah well I just
wanted to come on Google Bulls what I'm
saying yeah listen you heard down with
the
on Google Blair Blair what about you
would you would you do it uh no because
I have my SEO and search engine
optimization wins on my website and you
know and there's ways to make your your
website less SEO friendly yeah yeah just
tagged the wrong things link the wrong
link and the big thing is that there are
companies that you can actually pay to
bury all your search results so that you
know everything about you that's really
relevant or juicy or whatever is on the
seventh page of Google search when they
know that nobody ever goes you know I
love Twitter and I'm always on I tweet
you know and I a moat on Twitter and I
one I obviously don't care and I
obviously want people to be reading that
interact with people so part of me like
now I don't want to be on google because
I love to be able to communicate with
people and I love this business
strangers it's better than facebook like
the interaction you can have just people
out there in the world on Twitter then
there is another part of me that's like
it's like in real life like what if you
just wanted to disappear like you know
the Rings serious about being able to
think that there would be a service that
can make you just disappear up the
internet that's kind of like sexy them
into it wasn't that did Sandra Bullock
do a movie you know was what yeah wasn't
that sort someone erased her identity or
am I combining a couple move on like a
little tiny thumb drive it took minutes
ping ping ping in the back of the day
it's usually a murdered I don't know
yeah yeah tonight lied and said I had a
crush on Sandra Bullock which was not
true cuz honestly no one has a crush on
Sandra milk oh you were still trying to
be a great ready straight at that time I
surprised jazz ends at that level of a
bra yeah but you know what though isn't
that funny though how things happen so
quickly like when that movie the net
came out with Sandra Bullock it was
supposed to be a futuristic movie it
didn't come out that long ago maybe 15
years ago and it already feels through a
thumb drive man what would I did about
the terrible graphics lawnmower made it
was like virtually killing people
through the weird computer world as
before even internet on mowers and weird
yeah things to go after people yeah I
was at my at my grandma's house this
weekend and she had a CD that I wanted
to take
I don't even have a CD player at my
computer doesn't take CDs and I was like
how I literally i still haven't i'm like
i don't know what how would I even get
this device to be put on to my computer
at someone a great coasters they may I
what the views are so shiny on there
anyway technology is going fast if you
want to disappear from google there are
people that you can pay like in pretty
much everything else